let's go to our next caller from the
3:09 area code I think it is yeah 3:09
caller from 309 tell us who you are and
you can jump right into your question my
name is Jack and I was wondering if you
would ever livestream or debate with
smaller youtubers like three arrows or
atheism is unstoppable probably not I
mean to be perfectly honest I don't
listen here's here's the thing jack I
don't know about a lot of the youtubers
that people call in and they ask me that
I see this video or that video this it's
not about insulting anybody it's that
I'm trying to focus my activities on
those that will move the needle right
and when the show was much smaller
almost like appearing anywhere would
move the needle because if like we only
have 10,000 subscribers and I appear
somewhere with a channel that might have
10 20 or 30 thousand subscribers that's
a big impact on the show now that we
have half a million subscribers and 10
million views a month and the radio
stations and all the different stuff
it's usually like I'm I have so much
stuff to do related to my show that it
usually is not a good use of my time to
do like random small YouTube channels is
there a particular reason that you think
I should appear on those the two that
you just mentioned um it just seems like
it would be interesting yeah alright
well let's let's play it out if I did
appear and did a debate what would i
debate with those individuals um
politics most like politics okay very
good all right thank you for the call I
will certainly take it under advisement